[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRYAN ZIMMERMAN: As
you move to the cloud
and adopt the latest
technology, such as Kubernetes,
have you found it even harder
to find the root cause of issues
and understand just how well
your application is performing?
Stackdriver Application
Performance Management, a.k.a.
APM, shines light
on your cloud native
and multi-cloud
environments in order
to help you solve
these problems better.
I'm Bryan Zimmerman, Product
Manager for Trace and Debugger.
MORGAN MCLEAN: And I'm Morgan
McLean, Product Manager
for Stackdriver Profiler.
Stackdriver is Google's suite
of management and observability
products.
APM is focused on
that deeper levels
of debug-style
information to help
reduce mean time to resolution,
find performance optimizations,
and build the best possible
experience for your users
APM features three
products: Stackdriver Trace,
Stackdriver Profiler,
and Stackdriver Debugger.
BRYAN ZIMMERMAN: Trace is our
distributing tracing product.
What is distributed
tracing, you ask?
Well tracing allows you to
visualize how a request flows
through your environment.
In microservices, applications,
or highly distributed
environments, understanding
context and flow
is essential to
resolving problems.
MORGAN MCLEAN: How do we
use this in real life?
For example, let's
assume that we
receive an alert that
shows a jump in latency
for our application.
Trace gives us the
best detailed data
to help us troubleshoot
this error.
BRYAN ZIMMERMAN: With
Stackdriver Trace
you can easily see
the top requests,
RPC calls and
associated latency,
find an example of the issue
you having with simple search
and filter, and see a
simple view of the request
as it processes through
your complex environment.
This includes detailed custom
information and annotations.
MORGAN MCLEAN: For more
detailed information,
analysis reports are
generated automatically.
You can view an existing
report or create your own
to see how latency
has changed over time.
You can group
these by percentile
and you can also drill
down into example traces
to find out exactly what
happened to cause this issue.
BRYAN ZIMMERMAN: As you can see,
Trace guides you from problem
to service.
Now we will show you how you
can get from service to method
with Stackdriver Profiler.
MORGAN MCLEAN: Profiler can
inspect the CPU and memory
performance of all the
functions in your code,
and it shows you the calling
relationships between them.
Profiler can visualize your
code on a flame graph, which
shows calling relationships
along the vertical axis
and resource consumption
on the horizontal axis.
You can use a number of
different filters, including
weight filtering,
which only shows
data captured during
periods of high consumption,
and a focused filter, which
shows all of the paths
in and out of a
selected function.
If you need to visualize the
performance of functions that
are called throughout
your code base,
you could use the
focus table, which
shows the aggregated cause of
all the functions in the graph.
Finally, once you've
identified the area of code
that you're interested
in, it's time
to inspect the behavior of
this code to find the problem.
BRYAN ZIMMERMAN: This is
where Debugger comes in.
Stackdriver Debugger
offers the ability
to take log points and
snapshots of your running code,
in production, without impact,
redeploying, or restarting
your services.
Traditionally,
debugging involves
analyzing logs and metrics,
taking a guess at the problem,
deploying some new code or debug
module, looking at the logs
again to confirm,
waiting for the issue,
analyzing logs again, perhaps
taking another crack at it.
Stackdriver Debugger
allows you to take
breakpoints and
snapshots in production
without system impact,
redeploying, or restarting
your application.
This allows you to tighten
your troubleshooting flow
significantly, as you're
not having to wait
for lengthy deployments.
In addition to the
efficiency gains,
many customers report being
able to bring debugging further
up the troubleshooting
stack to operators or SREs,
further reducing MTTR and
affecting customer impact.
MORGAN MCLEAN: All of these APM
tools work with code and apps
that are running on
any cloud, or even
On-Premise infrastructure.
So no matter where you
run your application,
you now have a consistent,
accessible APM tool
kit to monitor and manage
the performance of your apps.
BRYAN ZIMMERMAN: With
Stackdriver Trace, Profiler
and Debugger, APM enables
developers and operators
to track and resolve issues
the way that Google Site
Reliability Engineering does.
You can start and stop your code
without affecting your users,
and get insights
into how your code is
running on production, no
matter what cloud you're using.
MORGAN MCLEAN: Whether your
application is just getting off
the ground, or if it's already
live and in production,
using APM to monitor and
tune it's performance
can be a game changer.
To get started with
Stackdriver APM,
simply link the
appropriate libraries
for each tool to
your application
and then start gathering
telemetry for analysis.
BRYAN ZIMMERMAN: To learn more,
visit cloud.google.com/apm.
MORGAN MCLEAN: And
thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]